nigeria has abolished the special
anti-robbery squad or
sars a police unit that as its name
suggests was
established to fight violent crime this
follows days of protests sparked by a
video shared on social media
of sars officers filmed in the alleged
killing of a civilian
demonstrators say that the ban of the
police unit doesn't go far enough
they're promising to keep campaigning
for sars officers to be brought before
the courts for their crimes
nigerians accuse agents from the police
unit of routinely
carrying out unlawful arrests torture
and even
murder his bruises are still fresh
after a violent attack a few weeks ago
kingsley amashi a taxi driver says
he was almost killed when passengers
assaulted him
he sold health from the police unit
stars but he says
that resulted in the officers trying to
make money off his case
next thing said to me was that i was
going to pay for investigation and i was
like
i can afford it and insisted that i have
to
give him some money i wasn't supposed to
give you a dime
i mean i i should i should be encouraged
for coming
alive you asking me for money is more
like killing me
more protesters say
it's common for sars to extort money the
police unit has even been accused of
torture and killings for the past few
days
protesters have been out on the streets
demanding an
end to the unit this is the young people
of nigeria saying that
enough is enough we keep getting
oppressed and brutalized and nothing is
changing
and we have leaders sitting there whose
core responsibility concessionally
is to protect the life of citizens when
are we going to matter
we are tired in nigeria's most populated
city lagos
protests usually last only a few days
people here can't afford to jeopardize
losing their jobs
but this time the protests have not
stopped not even after
sunday's announcement that the special
police unit will be dissolved
a campaign that started online is still
very much
active both on the streets and on social
media
with people now demanding the release of
arrested protesters
and justice for deceased victims
but kingsley doesn't believe that
dissolving stars will end police
brutality
in the country when you put a rotten egg
among good ones just give it a little
time
the good ones are not going to make the
bad one good rather the bad one is going
to make the good ones bad
let me suppress them and speak to
nigerians
we want to hear him want to feel that he
feels the pain we are going through
even if you're lying just say something
to us the founder of the movement
and sars who started the first online
campaign in 2016
is encouraging people on twitter to keep
on demonstrating
he doesn't want the protests to fizzle
out this time
without real reform
and earlier i spoke to sheikh unawa
sonya who's
mentioned there he's from the nsar's
online campaign
he's been pushing to have nigeria's
special anti-robbery squad disbanded
for years i asked him why demonstrators
are staying on the streets to protest
even after the government announced that
sars would be dissolved
justices are on the street because they
felt that this is just another political
pronouncement
and they want to be certain they need
assurances that did for this time around
that they are going to actually get what
they are asking for for many years from
2015 we've been caring about the
disbandment of serve
the evolution of sas and several other
things and it has not materialized on
ground
so this time around they want to be sure
that um
it's they are going for it that's why
they are demanding for a presidential
order
in that regard so despite the
announcement that's a
clearly a lack of trust in the police
and government
definitely the the trust in the police
have been
winged over the years because of um
violation of human rights and also
because of many things that
has been promised that was never kept
okay
um so if these protests are going on as
they are
what would be the measure of progress in
these reforms that would get people
satisfied
the reforms can actually be felt not in
the immediate
but much later and but for the people
they need to see that police are
actually respect is respecting human
rights on the street they need to see
that the abuse
is actually being abated but when police
say that
they have disbanded sides and they are
working on reform
and they want us to believe and they
want people to go back home the same
police officers who are trying to
uh um cop the protest are shooting at
people and killing innocent citizens
so when people see this it causes them
to lose trust in whatever promises that
police are making
so that's one of the reasons why it's
been doubted but the reform itself is
not the switch because we're engaging
culture and in order to
change what we have today you know we
need to work at it and it will take it
quite a while
but what they want right now are
low-hanging fruits the things that they
that can actually save them in other
words they want the bleeding to stop
so that we cannot begin to look at the
root cause and that bleeding
that we're talking about is police
impunity the act of
um violating human rights the
extrajudicial killings
the robbins and the rest of it so that's
what people want to be assured of so
that they can go back to their normal
life
knowing fully well that when they see
police officers they don't have to fear
for their lives okay nigerian police
don't
really have a good reputation so what is
it about
sars itself that has prompted this
outrage
yeah for over many years now cells have
been known to be the killer squad
of uh the police it's like the soldiers
within the police system
and it wasn't it was a 28 years old
adult program that have been called
cultured in impunity for quite a while
due to um institutional neglect or
dereliction
but over the years um people have been
keeping quiet about their abuses and all
until it became
the pattern became a culture and now
they tell you to your face that i'm
going to kill you and nothing will
happen and they actually
keep their promises so people now
with the advent of social media people
are now getting bolder
to report these crimes and to escalate
and that's where
people citizens and civil and society
organizations
started engaging and started blowing the
whistle on this
that was shagging our sonia of the nsars
campaign
talking to me from abuja